عاصفه الانسحاب الامريكي من افغانستان لم
تهدا بعد رغم مرور اكثر من سنه ونصف على
حدوثها فالتحقيقات لا تزال متواصله بشان
هذا الانسحاب الفوضوي وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه سمحت الاثنين من كبار اعضاء
مجلس النواب الاطلاع على نسخه ملقحه من
برقيه سريه بشان عمليه الانسحاب في هذه
الاثناء لا تزال واشنطن مهتمه بوجودها في
افغانستان طبعا رغم الانسحاب والسبب
مواجهته الحركات الارهابيه حيث اعلنت
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه استخدام جيل جديد
من الطائرات من دون طيار لزياده رحلات
الاستطلاع فوق افغانستان فبهذه الخطوه
يطمح الفينتاجون لمواصلات مراقبه الاراضي
الافغانيه لمواجهه طبعا اي تهديد ارهابي
لكن لماذا المسيرات السبب يعود لتجاوز قله
رحلات الاستطلاع الامريكيه في افغانستان
بسبب المسافه الطويله التي تتطلب التزود
بالوقت
ختاما نذكر بعناوين اخبار الساعه
القاده العربي يستعدون لقمه استثنائيه في
جده غدا والرئيس السوري الاسود بلاده
رغم بيانات النصر من الدفاع الروسيه
القاده العسكريين الروس من الانهيار
وادانات عربيه لاستفزازات اسرائيل في
القدس وواشنطن تحذر من تاجيج التوتر وتدعو
لضبط النفس
بعد تهم الفساد حاكموا مصرف لبنان يقول
للعربيه انه متعاون مع القضاء ويعلن انه
باقن حتى نهايه
ولايته لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات